of the losing side in World War II Italy
was the only major belligerent to avoid
occupation after 1945. it wasn't subject
to division like Germany was or forced
constitutional change like Japan instead
Italy was mostly disarmed lost its
overseas territories and was forced to
pay reparations but it was largely
rehabilitated within a couple of years
which raises the question why why wasn't
Italy occupied like the rest of the Axis
powers after World War II so as many of
you will know Italy was the first of the
major axis powers to admit defeat this
or King Victor Emanuel III order is
government to side with the allies and
fight against the axis forces that
remained in the north of the country and
as a result for the most part pragmatism
took over for the Allies the primary
concern for the US and UK was defeating
the Germans in the north and destroying
the Italian social Republic run by the
fez-wearing Italian man this meant that
unlike after Germany and Japan's defeat
the Allies didn't have the resources to
administer the day-to-day running of the
country as such many of those who had
served the fez-wearing Italian man were
essentially pardoned and Beyond this
Italy wasn't subject to massive
de-industrialization since it was easier
to manufacture things there for the war
effort and given that the war wouldn't
be over for another couple of years the
government remained largely stable so
what about after the war first of all
unlike Germany the USSR had no troops in
the country Yugoslavian communist
partisans had sent some of their troops
into the north but ultimately they could
be removed meaning that only the Western
allies were involved in Italy's post-war
settlement furthermore most of those who
had worked under mussolinian government
were staunch anti-communists and given
that the Cold War was about to begin in
Earnest that was good enough another
reason was that unlike Japan and Germany
there was no real desire for vengeance
against Italy the American people would
accept absolutely nothing less than
utter capitulation by Japan in response
to its attack on Pearl Harbor and
Germany's regime was seen as so evil
that any traces of it had to be
eradicated whereas Italy was just well
Italy Italy wasn't seen as a threat to
the very existence of any major Allied
Nation just some of their colonies and
some countries in southern Europe
furthermore in the United States there
was a large voting block of Catholic
Italian America and Roosevelt wanted to
win re-election Britain and France had
wanted to take a harsher tone towards
Italy they refused to prop up the
Italian monarchy and wanted much harsher
restrictions on its post-war military
but the United States simply overruled
their demands instead Italy would lose
its overseas Empire would demilitarize
its borders had strict limits on its
military equipment and wasn't allowed to
have nuclear weapons the reason why the
U.S could do this was that neither
Britain or France could spare the cash
of the troops needed for an occupation
these restrictions would last until 1949
when Italy joined NATO and it was
allowed to riyar because it sat on the
front lines of the cold war in Europe I
hope you enjoyed this episode with a
special thanks to my patrons James
bisonet Kelly moneymaker kosher wolf Sky
Chappelle kartoitska Adams daughter Alex
Schwinn Jerry lambdin Marcus Asner rod D
Martin a firefly Y and hockey Captain
psydog boogly Wiggly Marvin cassar
Winston caywood commune Yoon Miss izet
Maggie Paskowski Gustav Swan the mcgwapa
Anthony Beckett Coppertone sherwenin
spinning three plates words about books
podcast Jim Stromberg Spencer Lightfoot
and Charles III list